and they are police vehicles on the a2
not sure at this stage whether they are
involved in the chase but we do know
that police are chasing a vehicle along
the a2 a Peugeot has been stolen shots
fired near the area of damata on girl
hostages have been reported to be taken
in the town the report suggesting that
this vehicle was hijacked by two armed
gunmen at around about 20 to nine about
an hour ago now and these pictures are
now live and Martin monitoring them with
me and they don't seem to be going at
any particular fast speeds at the moment
bottom well it's difficult it's early oh
yeah and we don't know exactly what
these vehicles are doing but it it
perhaps is a large movement of the troop
of the the officers who were searching
the forest I mean I'm told that what's
happening now that the car chase is
happening about or some miles from the
forest area where the searches were
going on overnight so what it means
effectively is that huge amounts of
police will need to move in the
direction of of the two suspects and now
we're also told from one media source
here that relying on police sources that
at four o'clock this morning two armed
suspects entered a commercial building
we don't know what saw that it's a
restaurant or a hotel or something like
and that was after they had hijacked a
car a Peugeot 206 so some things happen
since four o'clock this morning
perhaps they were located by the police
it's prompted them to go on the move and
this is something of what we're watching
now on those those pictures of a convoy
of police vehicles moving as fast as
vehicles like that can flashing lights
at a great sense of urgency this I think
is the a2 motorway it's not